SECRETARY OF DEFENSE JAMES
MATTIS VISITING WITH U.S. TROOPS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER TODAY AS
A BREAKAWAY GROUP OF A FEW
HUNDRED MIGRANTS FROM THE
CARAVAN REACHES TIJUANA AND IS
SEEN CLIMBING THE BORDER FENCE.
SECRETARY MATTIS SAYING HE'S
CONFIDENT ABOUT SECURING THE
BORDER AS THE CARAVAN ARRIVES.
>> I AM 100% CONFIDENT WE HAVE
THE NUMBER OF TROOPS AT EACH OF
THOSE PORTS OF ENTRY TO COMPLETE
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO DO
PRIOR TO THE ARRIVAL OF THE
LARGE CARAVAN.
WHEREVER THEY CHOOSE TO GO.
>> Jesse: MATTIS STRIP COMES
AMID REPORTS PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
CONSIDERING REPLACING HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN.
TRUMP SANG A DECISION COULD BE
COMING SHORTLY.
THE QUESTION ON CAPITOL HILL,
WILL REPUBLICANS FINALLY BE ABLE
TO GET FUNDING FOR THE BORDER
WALL?
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN URGING
LAWMAKERS TO MAKE IT THEIR
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
>> THE SINGLE BIGGEST PROMISE WE
MADE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN 2016
THAT WE'VE NOT GOTTEN DONE YET.
BUILDING THE BORDER SECURITY
WALL AND SECURING THE BORDER.
WE SHOULD BE FOCUS ON THAT ONE
MAIN THING OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS AS WE STILL HAVE A FEW
WEEKS LEFT WHILE REPUBLICANS
CONTROL ALL OF GOVERNMENT.
WE SHOULD FOCUS ON THE BIGGEST
PROMISE WE MADE AND WHAT THEY
SENT US HERE TO DO.
>> Jesse: FORMER ACTING I.C.E.
DIRECTOR THOMAS HOMAN WARNING
THAT DEMOCRATS WILL TRY TO
TARGET I.C.E.'S BUDGET.
>> I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
LOOK TO CUT THE I.C.E. BUDGET.
LESS FUNDS, LESS ARRESTS, LESS
DEPORTATIONS, MORE CATCH AND
RELEASE.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
STRUGGLE WITH THE HOUSE UNDER
DEMOCRATIC CONTROL BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Jesse: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THE CARAVAN, SOME STRAGGLERS
BEAT EVERYBODY TO THE PUNCH.
THEY MADE IT TO TIJUANA.
HOW EASY IS IT TO CLIMB THE
WALL?
THEY ARE SITTING ON TOP OF THE
WALL, STRADDLING IT, THEY FALL
AND THEN THEY SCURRY BACK WHEN
THEY SEE ANY SORT OF PRESENCE ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
IT'S KIND OF A JOKE, ISN'T IT?
>> Geraldo: I THINK A NEW WALL
WOULD BE KIND OF A JOKE ALSO, A
30-FOOT HIGH MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR
WALL CAN BE EASILY DEFEATED BY A
$25 31-FOOT LADDER.
WHAT I'M RELIEVED IS THAT THE
DEMONIZATION OF THIS GROUP OF
PEOPLE --
>> Jesse: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
PROTOTYPE DOESN'T PREVENT
AGAINST LADDERS?
I THINK THEY TOOK THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION.
>> Geraldo: WALLS STOP JUAN
AND MARIA, THE FRUIT PICKER.
THEY DON'T STOP MS-13 AND
GANG BANGERS.
A WALL DOESN'T STOP PROFESSIONAL
CRIMINALS.
IT IS SO FIRMLY INGRAINED IN THE
AMERICAN PSYCHE THAT I HAVE
WITHDRAWN MY OBJECTION TO THE
WALL.
IF YOU WANT TO SPEND $25 BILLION
TO BUILD A WALL, GO FOR IT.
>> Jesse: BREAKING NEWS FROM
GERALDO.
>> Greg: I THINK THIS IS A SAD
STORY BECAUSE THIS WAS A
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED PHENOMENON
WHICH PAINTS A GROUP OF PEOPLE
AS CHEATING, LINE CUTTING,
TAKING ADVANTAGE.
IT WAS POLITICALLY MOTIVATED BY
ACTIVISTS.
THEY CLAIM THEY ARE FLEEING
DANGER FOR SAFETY BUT THEY ARE
FLEEING RIGHT THROUGH AND PAST
MEXICO WHICH IS OFFERING THEM
REFUGE.
IT'S LIKE DRIVING TO THE SECOND
HOSPITAL YOU SEE WHEN YOU ARE
SHOCKED, NOT THE FIRST ONE.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
THAT'S A CONTRADICTION.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT
AMERICANS ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
WE LIKE EMIGRANTS.
WE ARE IMMIGRANTS.
THIS POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
PHENOMENON TRIGGERED OUR SENSE
OF UNFAIRNESS AND LINE CUTTING.
YOU SPEAK OF WILL GET UPSET
BECAUSE THEY FEEL AMERICA IS
BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
THE REASON WHY THEY ARE GETTING
THERE FASTER IS THERE ARE BUSES
NOW.
THERE'S ALL THESE QUESTIONS THAT
NOBODY ANSWERED.
FOR EXAMPLE, HOW DID THIS START?
WHO STARTED IT?
HOW ARE THESE PEOPLE BEING FED
AND CLOTHED AND WHERE ARE THE
BATHROOMS.
HOW CAN THEY GO SO FAR SO
QUICKLY?
WE ARE SEEING THAT THEY ARE
USING TRANSPORTATION.
THIS IS ALL AN ARTIFICIALLY
CREATED PHENOMENON THEN
EVERYBODY COMES OUT LOOKING THE
WORST.
>> Jesse: AND THERE'S GOING TO
BE A BATTLE IN THE HOUSE,
KENNEDY.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO FUND THE
WALL AT ALL?
I HEARD 5 MILLION IS ON THE
TABLE FROM
SENATOR MITCH MCCONNELL.
5 BILLION.
EXCUSE ME.
AND THEN THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
DEFUNDING POSSIBLY WHEN PELOSI
TAKES OVER THE GAVEL OF I.C.E.
>> Kennedy: THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT AGE.
IT'S THE PROGRESSIVE WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE
MAINSTREAM DEMOCRATS, POPULIST
DEMOCRATS FROM THE MIDWEST DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF INTEREST IN IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
WHAT TO DO IN PLACE OF I.C.E.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM REPUBLICANS
RAN INTO REPLACING OBAMACARE.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A GREAT
SOLUTION AND PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GET SICK AND TIRED OF THAT BRAND
OF OBSTRUCTIONISM.
REPUBLICANS REALLY COULDN'T DO
MUCH WHEN THEY HAVE THE MAJORITY
IN BOTH CHAMBERS.
HOW ON EARTH ARE YOU GOING TO
CREATE A SENSE OF URGENCY JUST
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A COMPRESSED
TIMELINE?
THE INTERESTING THING HERE IS
YOU REALLY DO HAVE A SOLUTION.
DEMOCRATS HAVE SOMETHING THEY
WANT.
REPUBLICANS WHO SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT HAVE SOMETHING THEY
WANT, AND A FEW TRADE DREAMERS
FOR THE WALL, BOTH SIDES REALLY
ARE NOT FAR OFF IN THIS
COMPROMISE.
>> Greg: THAT IS TOO SENSIBLE.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE ACTIVISTS
ON BOTH SIDES.
THEY LOVE THE ENTRENCHMENT.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE ISSUES WHERE
EVERYONE WINS WHEN A GROUP OF
PEOPLE IS CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE.
CRUZ WAS A DEAL ON THE TABLE FOR
SOME REASON IT FELL APART.
MORGAN, THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
GETTING RID OF KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
TRUMP, IF YOU'RE GOING TO
BELIEVE THE MEDIA RIGHT NOW, IS
VERY UPSET WITH HER.
SHE'S NOT DOING ENOUGH ON THE
BORDER, AND HE'S THINKING ABOUT
REPLACING HER AS SOON AS
TOMORROW, WE ARE HEARING.
>> Morgan: SUPER HAPPY WE ARE
STILL TALKING ABOUT THE CARAVAN.
>> Jesse: THEY SAID FOX WAS
GOING TO STOP COVERING THE
CARAVAN.
THEY SAID FOX WAS GOING TO STOP
COVERING IT ONCE THE MIDTERMS
HAPPENED.
AND NOW WE ARE COVERING IT ON
"THE FIVE."
>> Morgan: EVERYBODY IN THE
CABINET SERVES AT THE PLEASURE
OF THE PRESIDENT SO IF THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO REMOVE
SOMEONE, THAT'S HIS PREROGATIVE
AS COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
WHEN I THINK IS IMPORTANT IS
THAT MATTIS WENT THERE AND YOU
KNOW I AM A NATIONAL SECURITY
PERSON AND I THINK BY MATTIS
GOING, HE REALLY SIGNALED THAT
THIS WAS A LEGITIMATE MISSION.
>> Jesse: HE SAID WE DON'T DO
STUNTS.
>> Morgan: HE ALSO TALKED
ABOUT IT BEING A MORAL ISSUE.
HE FRAMED WHAT HAPPENED A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO WHEN THE
MILITARY WENT TO THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MAY NOT LIKE THE
PRESIDENT'S OR MAKE FUN OF HIM
TALKING ABOUT THE WALL, WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT HIS STRONG
ACTION ON THIS AND HIS STRONG
WORDS, I THINK ARE REALLY
PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM GETTING
CLOSER.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING I THINK
IS ONE GERALDO SAID, THAT THAT
DREW PEOPLE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
FROM A NATIONAL SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE ARE NOT THE ECONOMIC
MIGRANTS OR THE REFUGEES.
THE REAL PROBLEMS IS GAINS IN
MS-13 AND THAT'S ALL YOU NEED
THE MILITARY AND THAT'S ALL YOU
NEED TO BEEF UP I.C.E. AND
THAT'S WHY MATTIS IS DOWN THERE
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT A FEW POOR
MIGRANTS.
>> Jesse: GERALDO, DO YOU
THINK THE ROOT OF BROGANS MAY
HAVE LOST SOME SEATS IN THE
HOUSE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
MAJORITIES AND THEY DIDN'T PAY
FOR THE WALL?
>> Geraldo: I DON'T THINK
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATION SEVERAL -- SET OF
DEFERRED THE DOUBLE MISFORTUNE,
THE MASSACRE IN THE JEWISH
SYNAGOGUE AND THE BOMBER
ATTENDING BOMBS OUT THE WEEK
BEFORE THE ELECTION GIVING
AMERICA A SENSE OF DISQUIET AND
LOOKING AT PRESIDENT TRUMP AS
BEING LESS THAN INVULNERABLE.
HE SEEMED RATTLED.
>> Jesse: TWO YEARS FROM NOW,
IF THERE IS STILL NO BORDER WALL
FUNDING AND THERE STILL CARAVANS
COMING, THAT'S GOING TO HURT
TURNOUT AMONG REPUBLICANS.
>> Geraldo: I HAVE URGED THE
PRESIDENT TO HIS FACE AND
CONVERSATIONS TO PLEASE TAKE THE
KENNEDY DEAL.
GIVE THE DREAMERS OF PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ALREADY SAID
THEY WOULD FUND THE WALL.
MAKE THEM STAND UP.
MAKE THEM DO THAT.
THE ELECTIONS HAVE CONSEQUENCES.
HE HAS EARNED HIS WALL, JUST AS
THE DREAMERS HAVE EARNED THEIR
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP.
I HAVE TO SAY YOU REFERENCED
SOMETHING SECRETARY MATTIS HAD
ABOUT 100 YEARS AGO, 150 YEARS
AGO ARIZONA, NEW MEXICO,
COLORADO, CALIFORNIA AND ALL
THESE OTHER STATES BELONGED TO
MEXICO.
SO THERE'S A SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP THAT HAS TO BE
RECOGNIZED.
WE HAVE 7 MILLION UNFILLED JOBS
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE FRUIT AND VEGETABLES
DYING ON THE VINE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GET OFF THE
DIME, FORCE OUR POLITICAL
LEADERS RIGHT AND LEFT, RED,
BLUE, REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT, FIX
THE PROBLEM.
ENOUGH ALREADY.
ENOUGH GRANDSTANDING.
>> Greg: I GET THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PEOPLE TO DO
THESE JOBS BUT THE ONE THING
THAT DRIVES ME CRAZY ABOUT THIS
IS THAT WHENEVER YOU ARE FOR LAW
AND ORDER, WHETHER IT'S FOR
PRISONS, STRONG BORDERS OR
TERROR, THE OPPOSING SIDE IS
ALWAYS GOING TO SAY YOU ARE
AGAINST A CERTAIN GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE ALWAYS GOING TO BE
PAINTED IS MEAN.
IF YOU HAVE A STRONG BORDER, YOU
DON'T LIKE BROWN PEOPLE.
IF YOU ARE -- IF YOU WANT -- IF
YOU ARE STRONG ON TERROR, YOU
ARE ISLAMAPHOBIC.
IF YOU WANT A STRONG CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, YOU JUST WANT TO
INCARCERATE MORE BLACKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOW TODAY HE'S
NOT.
IF YOU ARE LAW AND ORDER PERSON,
THE ONLY ARGUMENT YOU ARE GOING